all right um let's get uh started good
afternoon everyone it's great to see a
large turnout today and uh welcome to
today's theoretically speaking
presentation uh is machine check proofs
and the rise of formal methods in
mathematics so my name is wenat
guruswami I'm a senior scientist here at
the Simons Institute and also an acting
acting interim director of the semester
um so just a brief introduction to the
Simons Institute uh the Simon Institute
is the leading international venue for
collaborative research in theoretical
computer science and related fields uh
it was established in 2012 with a very
generous Grant from the Simons
Foundation which continues to support us
um the institute's model is it brings
together together the world's leading
researchers in theory of computing
related fields as well as the next
generation of outstanding young scholars
post doogs visiting students fellows and
so on and the the main mode of operation
is to have thematic semester programs
usually two of them run in parallel and
uh but we also run a lot of uh Outreach
activities with the goal of popularizing
algorithmic thinking and and its
importance in addressing current um day
challenges and one such series is the
theoretically speaking series and the
idea here is to um highlight exciting
advances in theory of computing
algorithms all broadly construed uh for
a broad audience so the topics of sort
of of general interest and uh and you
know the talk sometimes even attract
high school students and you know
supposed to be interally accessible and
I'm very excited to uh introduce uh
today's theoretically speaking uh uh
speaker uh today Who's dardo d Mora so
I'll give a brief uh bio of him and then
then
lead let him give the talk so lenardo is
a senior principal applied scientist in
the automated reasoning group at AWS and
in his spare time he serves as the Chief
Architect and member of the board of
directors of the lean frro Focus
research organization which is a
nonprofit organization uh that he
co-founded with Sebastian ulri and uh
before joining AWS uh this year uh he
was a senior principal researcher in the
r group at Microsoft research where he
worked for 17 years and his research
areas span many topics including
automated reasoning theorem proving
decision procedures sat and
smt and he's the main architect of lean
which is an open source theorem prover
and programming language as well as Z3
and yikes 1.0 which are both smt solvers
as well as um salal or symbolic analysis
laboratory which is an open source tool
that includes symbolic and bounded model
checkers
and uh today's talk will be on formal
methods in mathematics for you know
machine assisted proofs uh and so on and
uh and I just want to say that it's it's
quite
remarkable that we are at a point today
where you can in a reasonable span of
time code up formalize and verify the
highest level of mathematical research
and I think I mean some of seeing some
of these developments in the last couple
of years I've been quite astounded and
so it's a great pleasure today to uh
invite uh lonardo Deora to tell us about
uh uh this this journey and I'm sure
there's a lot more to come in this space
in the Years ah thank you very
much thank you very much for for the
introduction V cat and for the
invitation very happy to be here
uh our story starts with formal methods
right uh I'm actually not a
mathematician I'm computer scientist and
my area of expertise is formal methods
right in formal methods we specify we
design in veryy complex systems with
mathematical RoR right we may use
automated provs or or interactive
ones
uh but here's an example right what do I
uh what I mean by specification you can
write for example a very simple
specification for the uh a function that
the maximum of two numbers right this
specification has three parameters A and
B the inputs and the results and the
spec here is basically saying the result
should be greater than or equal to a
right should be greater than or equal to
B and it should be equals to A or B
right and then we have the design this
the actual function our implementation
in this case and you have the
verification step where we we are
proving that this our implementation
such as
the specification right of course we may
make mistakes in the specification right
and we may this is a common thing a
common question people ask us right you
may be proving the wrong thing your
specification may be wrong but you can
test specifications too right how do we
test we such proving properties about
our
specifications we may say well supp that
we specify the real numbers we may try
to prove the real number for a real real
close algebraic Fields right uh and you
can make it this test for everything you
can prove properties about your
specifications you can inspect them and
you're going to see later today that you
can use tools to navigate these
specifications and increase your
confidence that they are
correct but the cool thing about formal
proofs right is that there are machine
checkable right you can write a small
program that can check formal proofs
right formal proofs they have a lot of
detail right they may be T to write by
hands but today you have machines that
can assist us creating formal proofs and
we have these small trusted proof
Checkers we can have many of them right
here I have a very simple proof right
basically showing that if you have aals
B and Cal B you can prove that AAL C
right how do we do that you can see that
the actual proof looks like a program
right and basically H2 here you can view
as a as a certificate or or a or
evidence that Cals B since you have
evidence that Cals B we are giving a
name to the evidence calling is Age
Two we can use symmetry to get now
evidence
that bals c and now that we have
evidence we have H1 that's evidence that
a equals B and we have evidence that b
equals c you can get a proof the
transitivity gives you a proof that a
equals c right this is a formal proof in
our system that we are going to study
today and why machine uh checkable
proofs are relevant from mathematics we
claim they're the ultimate democratizer
right right the things now when you have
a formal proof nobody should take on
faith or authority the things you say
right it doesn't matter who you are
where you came from if your proof can be
checked everybody can build on top of it
right IT addresses the trust botton NE
not just the trust between humans right
sometimes we see very tiny groups maybe
only two mathematicians working together
because they don't trust each other they
are working with their close
collaborators machine checkable proofs
allow people that never met to work
together and now with AI right that's
coming from athematics to we will
address the bot the trust Boton NE
between humans and machines right with
machine checkable proves you you don't
need to trust the AI you can give the
spec you only have to be sure that your
spec is correct if it produces a proof
right you don't need to check
if it's a formal proof you can check if
this more trusted program the proof
Checker uh link is the proof assistance
we build right is the work of many many
different people right there many many
different contributors right it's based
on dependance type Theory the main goals
for the project are
extensibility and I will emphasize that
because extensibility is the most
important one we for for we started
project 10 years ago with very little
resources only now we have a foundation
that's we can hire Engineers to work on
this project having extensible system
allows the community to contribute to
the system we do not have to coordinate
they can extend the system independently
of our wishes as developers of the
system we once expressed
system A system that you can express
modern mathematics dependence type
theory is powerful enough for that
scalability is really important a huge
mathematical library is a beast right is
a big Software System and efficiency is
also important nobody wants to keep
waiting the system to check your proofs
or to what should I do next you want
instantaneous reaction a common
complaint we get from mathematicians is
this is is low I have two weights and
you have to go back and try to make
things
faster uh you may ask lean may have bugs
yes it may have bugs but you only need
to trust the proof Checker you may have
a huge system to assist humans creating
this proofs you can put AI in the mix
you can have graphical user interfaces
you can have data basis but in the end
you have a formal proof and this formal
proof is checked by a small Pro
We Believe L is a platform for
formalized mathematics right software
development and verification and also a
platform for developing new proof
Automation and domain specific
languages we have this is multra Kernel
this proof
Checker and we support external type and
proof Checkers this is important right
so our C may be small but it may contain
bugs you you you address this issue by
allowing people to implement their own
Checkers
right here is an example of a I'm
putting here just to give you a flavor
of how a ling proof looks like you can
view Ling as a development environments
for formal methods right all your proofs
and definitions are machine checkable
the math Community using Ling is growing
rapidly right I never expected that I
mean
originally we want you the main customer
fling we expected to be software
developers that want to verify their
software we still want care about
software verification we thought some of
magicians would care about this kind of
system but we never expected that they
would like so much the system right you
can also see L as a compiler for
mathematics now right you have a high
level language this language that the K
accepts is like Assembly Language for
mathematics nobody wants to write proofs
in this language they create their own
notations we provides notations for them
to to operate the system in a high level
of abstraction and Link compiling this
high level language that's not just
designed by us but by our users too to
this lowlevel kernal language and of
course they use integrated development
environment these editors that's develop
used to write codes is the same editors
right that people used to write codes
mathematicians now use to write
proofs here's an example of L for for
formal mathematics I got a piece of math
lib just to give you an idea this is a
result from the stack library right
stack is this big Open Source book it's
Columbia University right it's huge
right and it's really hard to find
results there here by having the formal
versions you get many benefits one
benefit you make sure the proofs are
correct this is great but it's more than
that because by making mathematics into
formal moving from informal to formal
math now is also data you can search
it's easier to search it's easier to
track dependencies is easy to factor
your codes you you can build dependency
graphs you can do you can analyze is the
structure of your proofs you can write
meta programs programs that Traverse
your definitions
right and here you can see how rich you
have commutative Rings sub modules ideos
module aditive commutative groups you
have all these elements being used to to
state this
theorem uh a question that we get all
the time should we trust link right
maybe it's full of bugs yes it's full of
bugs is a huge system with contributions
from many different people right but we
don't need to trust the whole system you
only need to trust the Checker right but
the Checker may have bugs our Checker
may have bugs but you don't need to
trust it you can export your proof right
and you can use external Checkers over
the years many checkers have been
implemented for link for high SCH Scala
rust and so on now in the latest version
we're reporting many of these Checkers
to the latest
version uh and this is importance we
really believe this is the way to
achieve to make sure our results are
correct right to make sure the
mathematicians trust the system they're
not concern as that they are proving
something that's not true and finally
you can Implement your own checker many
people do that right some of these
Checkers were written by students like
some students want to understand how the
theory works right and the best way to
understand it is to implement your own
checker right it's a fun activity so
this high school was a friend of mine he
implemented one week this check
has in Lan enable decentralized
collaboration right as I said L
extensible system right and there are
two main pillars that support the centr
izes collaboration in link one is meta
programming meta programming is that you
can extend link using link itself right
you can write link programs right that's
are mathematical definitions link
functions that are mathematical
definitions uh some link functions are
proofs and some link functions are Lan
extensions right there are new proof
automation there are visualization tools
new custom notation
or refactoring tools we can do that all
in link this graph here this dependency
graph was created by the community right
for they formalized a result they want
to see how the
dependency graph is for these results
and they autogenerated this graph just
tracking again Mathis data formal math
is data you can check the dependencies
you know which Lama
is using and you can check which Lamas
these Lamas are using you can keep going
back back back until you get back to
aums you can check all the dependencies
and you can use color codes for the
modules these dependencies come
from this is very powerful right I
didn't Implement I mean none of my
colleagues that helped me developed L
implemented this graph was implemented
by the
community formal proofs right is the
second ingredients right for pro as I
said they uh they are the ultimate
democratizer you don't need to trust me
to use my proofs right you don't need to
trust my proof automation to use it we
say like in the breast Community you can
hack without fear you can create a new
kind of proef automation without fear
you may be introducing unsoundness
you're adding a bug to the system
suppose that you write a proof
automation that is buggy what will
happen it will create a proof when this
proof goes to the Kel to the proof
Checker the Checker is going to say this
is a invalid proof and people will
realize that the automation you build is
incorrect if it has so many bugs people
will stop using your
automation sometimes buggy automation is
useful if it works most of the time some
people use it anyway because because
they it's making them more
productive formal proofs are are key
right allows you to implement proof
automation without worrying if it always
works you can Calla sometimes external
tools to construct these proofs
Implement is in a completely different
language in the end you only care about
this certificate this formal
proof the mathematical library right is
called math living Ling is developed by
a huge Community right this is the
picture these are just the maintainers
there are way more people there more
than 300 people that contributed to the
library the Le mathematical Library they
have a paper where it's impossible to
list all the authors right you take
several Pages they just say the mab
Community as the author of this of this
page here's some statistics the library
has more than one million lines of codes
right it started in
20177 has more than 100,000 theorems and
the contributions for from more than 300
people the library is the foundation of
many other projects like the perfectoid
spaces these project popularized Link in
2018 Kevin Bard said
well all the prefer systems formalized
important results in mathematic
but these results are not fashionable
anymore there's nobody working on these
results they important but there results
from the past the toid space is a hot
area in 2018 Peter shows God F metal
right and everybody want to understand
what a perfect space because he worked
in this area he created this
concept and in math oflow you can find
this question or are perfectoid spaces
the second most voted question is a link
to the link developments right basically
the answer is a Perfecto space is a
typing link and this these developments
you go there you can navigate the
results right now is almost like a
browser for example uh the picture is a
little small but it says that a perfect
space depend on depends on some
something called a tate ring you may not
know what Tate ring is but you can ask L
jump to the definition of Tate ring and
you can read of f ring is maybe it's
defined using all the things you don't
know and you can keep jigging jigging
and learning until you fully understand
what a Perfecto space is there's no I
mean sometimes when people give
explanations in formal math they they
remove the details they can go back to
the aums right so otherwise the
explanation would be enormous right
nobody would read it it's hard to to
modulate how precise should we be in
formal mathod this problem doesn't exist
you can keep jigging jigging asking for
more and more details and you can fully
if you have
patience even if you do not have the
background but you have patience you can
understand anything right you can keep
jigging and finding more and more about
these objects and this attractive many
this project attracted many
mathematicians to the link
Community today the L ecosystem has the
mathematicians where with many projects
like math Le F fly pitch LMO spaces the
formal abstract projects there are many
projects there but there's a lot of
activity in AI I will go back to AI
later
today uh there are also software
developers that a language that's great
for math is also a language that's great
for programming that people that use
Link for many different applications for
checking protocols controlling robots
and so on and we also strong believe
that formal mathematics is also useful
for math education right I meet all the
time young students that learn to
program by themselves right without any
help they keep reading tutorials playing
online
they can play they have a playground a
interpreter a compiler that they can run
programs and tests and and play with it
for math it is harder right usually you
have to have a mentor someone that tells
you this is a proof this is not a valid
argument this is not rigorous this is
incorrect you need someone to guide you
until now now you can do math like you
program
right it's funny all these students that
learn to program themselves is really
easy to teach them to use formal
mathematics some of them say I don't
know what a proof is you sit one
afternoon with then they will learn what
a proof is it's very similar to
programming the L liip channel is where
the community gathers there are many
streams there and people interact you're
going to find all different sorts of
people there you find students
commemorating their achievements like oh
I this my bachelor dissertation using
Ling or asking basic questions but you
also find Peter shows it there working
with people formalizing liquid tensor
experiments you find AI people talking
about building AI from mathematics on
top of Ling and so
on uh in
2020 was the year that L start becoming
very popular uh we had an article in the
Quant and wir magazine talking about the
mathematical library and Quant selected
Ling as one of the biggest breakthroughs
in math and computer science they
interviewed many many different members
of the community from Young students to
establish
mathematicians it gave me a boost to
work hard and many quotes
there I was really happy with many of
the codes from people from the community
was the first time I realized the power
of the community how people together can
achieve
more in 20201 had the liquid tensor
experiments when Peter show posed this
challenge he had this new results he
claimed that was the most important
result of his career he already had a
Fields medal by then and he was saying I
have a new results I'm unsure about this
results I have my lecture notes people
are using them and nobody's checking the
proof I'm not sure about the proof and
he posed this challenge can you check
this proof using formal mathematics
right and I remember when
Kevin approached me saying they you were
going to do it uh they conjecturing that
would take years to formalize this kind
of mathematics right this Cutting Edge
math that's not even Peter sh could keep
every all the details on his head right
but people in a few months they managed
to prove the main result he wasn'ts sure
about and after several months they
formalized the whole thing their
development showed up in nature news and
and was I think the biggest achievements
up to that
point this this talk about Johan kin he
led the formalization efforts this is
amazing talk I invites all of you to go
there and watch is available online it's
an amazing talk and and it shows how you
can approach mathematics as an engineer
Yan doesn't know but he's an amazing
engineer he modularizes everything he
create the right
specifications the the he defined the
right abstraction boundaries after he
did that he could paralyze the community
could say you prove that you prove this
you prove that and everybody could work
in parallel
right and
there are many takeaways right from this
project it's not just about we checked
the proof but also the main take away
that form mathematics is a tool for
reducing the cognitive loads right it's
not just about raw proof complexity
right it's
discrepancies discrepancies between
statements and proofs missing size
conditions unstated assumptions right
that many tiny errors here and there
Yan told me that in in many many
different proofs he could see only two
steps ahead he only managed to do it
because there's a computer next to him
helping him he can see the proof states
he can inss the proof states he looks
the informal proof he couldn't make
sense of it using pen and paper but you
a computer he managed to do it he just
not checked the proof he and his team he
simplifies the proof this is mindblowing
when they told shows that they simplify
the proof without fully understanding
the proof it's insane it's because you
have a computer next to you assisting
you along the
way uh and also Le also impact how
mathematics is done this new results
right from from Thomas
Bloom they formalized the results before
it was referees right and you have a
tweet from Ching goers the fields
medalist saying oh wow it's the first
time I see this happening the result has
been formalized before he was refereed
right may be the sign of things to come
he finishes his
sentence another interesting project is
the sphere rsion projects right is that
you can flip the the sphere inside out
many people were wondering if it's even
possible to do that in a proof
assistance how do you do this kind of
proof in a proof assistance it is just
uh many people conjecture that proof
assistance will work we work only well
for number Theory
algebra for for things like geometric
top topology they were wondering if it
would work or not they not only
succeeded but they design new ways to
attack this problem and also they used
this system that was also built by the
community the
blueprints the blueprints allows you to
create a bridge between the informal and
formal worlds this blueprint has been
used in the sphere Rion projects in the
liquid tensor in the the previous one by
Thomas Bloom it allows you to visualize
the result as you would a regular uh
math result using formal mathematics but
it has links for the formal version and
maintains D sync
right uh 2003 has been a great year for
link I mean has been mentioned in the
New York Times t St mention it it was in
Quantum magazine again right because of
the importance of formal mathematics and
AI there's a strong relationship I will
tell you more about that later
uh the mathematical library was also
ported to L4 the latest version L4 is a
big red design of the link system right
it's a much more powerful version but is
incompatible with the previous one when
we started Lan four math Li was Tiny we
never imagine when we started Lan four
developing L for math Li was like 40,000
lines of codes we thought well it's
going to be not going to Backward
Compatible but we can't CH Port
everything by hands right it's not big
deal 40,000 lines we have each one of us
can port a few thousands we will be done
in one
month but we never expected that would
be more than one million lines right
would grow so
rapidly and everybody I lost count how
many people would come to me and
saying this is going to be like Python 3
and python 2 going to stay forever two
versions of Link because it will be
impossible to P the whole Library I had
doubts many times if this if it was
going to be possible to Port but the
community managed to Port they managed
to Port the whole library and they
finished the PST the same at the same
day that was the commemoration of the
10th of anniversary of the
system uh also Ling has been used uh
recently for uh
cryptography Danielle bin is a famous
cryptographer that's formalized as Goa
codes using link and also gron hor the
creator of rust was also motivating
people to learn Lan and saying that he's
really impressed with the system and a
powerful research
language extens ability let's talk a
little bit about extensibility I told
you that we want to make Ling extensible
we want the community to extend the
system and add their own
features let's tell you how they do it
first thing math Li is not just math is
1.2 million lines but between 40,000 and
50,000 lines they are meta
programs they are Lan extensions right
the community extends Lan using lean
itself here's an example the ring ttic
for for solving equations in ring theory
is a ttic written by the community right
a kind of proof automation written by
the community I'm just giving you a
fragment but this is link codes is the
same language you use for writing proofs
and mathematical definitions you can
write
extensions then for because we want
people to write their own extensions
their own proef automation we also want
it to be an efficient programming
language just to give you an idea the
Lan memory manager is now the being a
memory manager the memory manager was
designed by Dan lion a friend of mine
Dan designed for Le the memory manager
he never expected he to be honest we
didn't care about being
right but it do out that the Le memory
manager is great reduce the Laten of
Bing right Bing responds more
efficiently now because of the memory
manager that's used in
l l also uses a technique called
functional but in place that functional
programming languages are not to be
inefficient but this recover some of the
deficiency we find in imperative
programming
languages and proofs are not just for
proving terms you can also use proofs
optimizing your codes and this is one
thing that we want to keep pushing this
direction making ling a better and
better programming
language ling a big topic domain
specific languages we have many of them
L has an extensible passer you may say
oh why do you want extensible pass here
is because mathematicians love creating
their own notations right and they want
a system that you can do that right uh
and making a system having a hygienic
macro system hygienic macro system is a
microsystem that you cannot
accidentally capture names you cannot
write things that's have tiny bugs is a
high level description of a hygienic
micro system yes our goal was simple
extensions should be simple right that
was the goal we want if you want to
write a simple notation you're
mathematician you want to write a simple
notation you should not have to read a
lot of API should be very simple right
and this infrastructure is uses
everywhere even for implementing
like we have this little language called
we call do notation for writing code
that looks like imperative codes in Ling
but it's just notation behind the scenes
it's functional codes ling a pure
functional language this is just an
illusion right it feels like doing a
destructive update here it's just an
illusion right is just to make
convenience for people to write codes
for writing their Pro Automation and for
us to write Lan itself Ling is
implemented in Lan L for is implemented
in Lan and we use the notation that we
create for the users ourselves to
implement the
system uh and is everywhere right the
proof automation we write is using this
do notation right this is the automation
we use for proving congruence lemas
congruence lemas is when you have F of
aals f of
B sorry when you have AAL B implies F of
AAL F of B the congruence Rule and we
want to propagate this lemas and this is
the piece of automation that creates
this proofs for you right it's written
in Le using the that's do notation I
told you I just told you about we it's
everywhere you find this do notation
everywhere the TCH framework right also
known as the synthesis framework it's a
framework where you can create proofs
using commands you can say I want to
prove this theorum using induction right
you have a command called induction you
can say apply ACC intro you're applying
a result a previous results you can
introduce a variable right all this
building blocks you have this notation
called that starts with a buy when you
say by in link is you you switch to this
new domain specific languages a domain
specific language language forat
improves and by the way is the most
popular GSL in L it's the most popular
with the mathematicians they love this
this GSL uh if you meet Kevin Buzzard of
Patrick M they youran they would say no
no we love ttic framework we love to
because it's like a playground you can
keep executing commands and seeing the
results you can see the proof States you
can apply transformations to your proof
States manipulating the
object interactively right I mean and
they love this
language and you can extend yourself
using Ling again this is the the tactic
right this a proof automation for doing
case analysis again Implement
implemented in L using the do notation
right users can write their own new PR
for the static language like the ring
tactic I showed you before everything is
implemented in
L this is a thing that I
emphasize sometimes people say oh this
not big
deal but convenience is key right here
because you don't have to learn a new
language you do everything L sometimes
mathematicians in the same file they
write proofs and proof Automation in the
same file it's convenience to do that
and they love it convenience is super
important in any system any computer
system people want easy things should be
easy right you have to remove all the
roadblocks if you had to compile a
separate thing dynamically
link learn a different language it's too
much work here you make it super easy
for someone to extend the SE system and
that's why they do
it there are many challenges ahead right
L has one million lines but if you want
to keep up with modern
mathematics we estimate we would need to
add 10 million lines per year right this
poses many many
challenges and to attack these
challenges we now have the folks
research
organization the F this is a concept
created by converence research Arch as a
new model for science the key idea of
conversions is that there are projects
that you need a focus efforts right we
need Engineers for long a long period of
time right you need a chain you need
resources this and they claim this too
big for Academia Academia today is not
prepared to have a huge team of
Engineers working on a
project and also for industry some there
are projects like C there's no clear
profitability path right you're not
going to make money building a system
for
mathematics who funds that right and the
f is a model for this kind of projects
we just one the lingo is just one of the
many fros that exist today there are 10
and many more will exist in the future
and the mission of the f is to address
the scalability usability improve
automations in link by the end of the
year we're going to have seven full-time
employees and it is supported by the
Simons Foundation the off loan
foundation and resarch markeing we're
super grateful for their supports right
maybe now it would be impossible to push
the system you reach the points that
there's so many things if you look the
issue tracker for the link project on
GitHub there are more than 500 issues
when you have real users you have real a
bunch of issues right any real project
has tons and tons of issues you need a
team to address the people asking all
sorts of improvements
features uh usability concerns and you
need a team to address
that and there's also scale I mean just
this a question uh Joseph Myers posted
on zulip right he ask what will happen
if math lies the communi is 100 times
bigger the library is 100 times bigger
and you have 100 times more commits
right what do we going to what we going
to do if this happens
right if it's 100 times bigger it's
going to be 120 million lines of this is
bigger than most software systems this
is bigger than Windows right everything
is complicated just building a project
of this magnitude is complicated right
so scale is key right how do you address
skillability issu is a big problem right
then you have to design new algorithms
new data structures they're engineering
like oh we going choose memory Mage
files improving the code
generator I have a here picture of the
algebraic hierarchy this is just a tiny
fragment it is gigantic that thousands
of classes of mathematical objects in
this
hierarchy
automation right mathematicians love to
write proof sometimes they I get
really Blown
Away the efforts they put right in these
proofs keep in mind that in a system
like lean you cannot say this is obvious
I'm going to skip this step right you
have to prove everything you have Pro
automation to fill in the gaps but the
pre automation is not strong enough to
cover every single this is obvious you
find in formal math there are many steps
in formal math that people say this is
obvious but we don't have ma programs
proof automation that can produce the
proof automatically for this kind of
Step today right we need to improve that
there is something called the overhead
factor or the bran Factor this is the
overhead of using formal mathematics
when you compare results right you get
the informal results and you compare for
the formal version and how much bigger
the formal version is for the liquid
tensor experiments it's 20 right is a
lot it's to many time if you compare
Show's lecture notes with the formal
version it's 20 times bigger right and
we want to make it smaller right as we
keep imagine if one day you can make it
less than one by making it formal you
can you can write less that should be
amazing right that should be
unbelievable usability is another thing
right uh and there are many many
improvements of in this area right is a
many people from many different
institutions helping us to get a great
user
interface here is showing the proof
State the proof state is not a fix is
interactive object
you can start clicking you can visualize
these objects you can visualize implicit
information you can make implicit
information that you hide because you
don't want to overload people with all
the details but you can start clicking
and inspecting every single detail and
you have tools like oh jump to the
definition show me all the references of
this every place where this result is
used you can ask this questions
right you can use autoc completion like
we use when you're programming you're
typing something and shows you
suggestions to autoc complete all these
features that you find in regular
programming languages you find
in Trace messages you may say what's a
trace message is basically to show you
the be what's happening behind the
scenes sometimes the hardest part is
understand when pref automation work
it's great everybody's happy but when it
does not work sometimes it's really
tricky to understand why it didn't work
you expect wow I thought the pref
automation would work here why didn't
work understanding why something didn't
work is a big Challenge and Trace like a
log of everything the Prov did is
important but if this log is just a
bunch of strings it's really hard to
navigate sometimes it's gigantic but in
L the log is a object is a link object
like any theorem in definition and you
can browse it is an interactive object
too you can search it you can browse it
you can inspect
it
and now you can also create your own
visualizations for the mathematical
objects in this case actually is a red
black tree for computer science red
black tree is a data structure it's a
balance tree right for storing elements
and you can have logarithmic time itri
finds if elements is there or
not and in L now you can Define your own
visualization in link this in this file
you are defining the
visualization right so defining how to
visualize a red black tree and now when
we proving something about red black
trees you have the proof States you can
select a th that represents red black
tree and it will generate the graph
automatically for you you will generate
a graphical visualization of the red
black tree this is not hard coded in the
system the user defined how they want to
visualize the the tree you can change
and this is a live objects for example
I'm if I click here on Z is going to say
oh Z has Type Alpha right is an
interactive graphical representation of
your object and you can Implement any
visualization you want right this is uh
great when you're are in a complex proof
you can create
visualizations for your mathematical
objects and see them as you trying to
prove your your
results
uh challenges language nobody knows how
form mathematics should look like
there's no spec everybody's learning as
we go we are learning as we go there are
many components there we have coions
overload notation implicit there are so
many different things but the main
challenge is there's no spec every new
Gadget must have a well- defined
semantics the communi is always giving
feedback and to be honest they overwhelm
us with all the feedback Sometimes some
feedback is in the right direction
sometimes in the wrong direction it's
really
challenging engineering people ask
sometimes oh we are computer
scientist uh yes but we are also
Engineers right there's a lot of
Engineering in a system like
that go from even for building I mean
you want to build math Li you want to
check every single thing in me this is
like a build process is a complicated
process a package manager right math lip
today is a monor rle it's great from for
many different reasons is a monor rle is
a consistent view of mathematics there's
only one ring in math Le there's only
one field everything it's not like
sometimes computer science library is
that you have many different lists many
different arrays you have
implementations of the same thinking
many different packages here you have
only one thing right you have one ring
one field one definition of real numbers
and so on but it puts new challenges
right it can be a monor repo forever
right we need a package manager to
progress we need documentation
generators you need continuous
integration this Parts actually the
community I would never expect the
continuous integration from F Le is like
a professional software development
environment you get pool requests you
have reviews there's a team of reviewers
there have more than 30 reviewers people
that checks if the contributions meets
the quality criteria they
want it's a lot is a lot I mean my
points I'm trying to make in these
slides that there a lot of
engineering now let's to
to one the Hot Topic now is AI right
everybody that many many different
groups trying to build AI for
mathematics we all know large language
models are incredible incredibly
powerful tools right but they also
hallucinate here's an example that a
friend of mine sent me for fun I mean we
were talking about I was excited telling
him about language models he just sent
me oh ask
CH4 this question show me that the
infinitely many integers between two dis
integers and it comes up with these
arguments right some people may be
fooled and believe whoa there are
infinite inte between any two distinct
integers it makes some sense that I mean
obviously they mistakes right like this
step you follow up trying
to make it admit it error no no he just
gave me this part but keeping mind I
find gp4 actually can recover to some
extent
but you have to understand you have to
go here now you may believe this is true
these arguments right and accept it like
yeah it's
great formal proof is are antidote true
hallucinations right and there are many
different groups building AI for
mathematics on top of lean because we
have a huge mathematical Library if you
want to come up for proof a formal proof
this proof needs a lot of mathematics it
doesn't come uh from F air you have the
you need the definitions the results the
theorems right and having a huge
mathematical library is key right that's
why many groups are building AI forf on
top of Link because you can create this
formal proofs that can be checked and we
have a gigantic mathematical library for
example open AI a few years ago they
wrote a system on top of L that can
solve some olymp had problems right this
one is from IMO 1964 problem two the
proof is very simple in he using a piece
of atic NL AR but there's the magical
step he came up with thiss right this is
the Magic in in this proof everything
else is mechanical but coming up with
this THS was the was the uh was machine
using machine learning right
that AI also built a system right and it
was really well integrated with in link
tree right uh in your proof it would
suggest many different tactics what you
should try
next there's also something called autof
formalization the process of converting
informal math into formal one of course
this is just a beginning I mean we're
not there yet but imagine a day that you
can interact with this kind of system
using informal mathematics everything's
being converted to formal behind the
scenes right this project here link
chats is the f one of the first attempts
right you start writing in English it
gives back the link version of this
statement written in English you keep
intering you say oh this is not
completely right he place order by order
off and you keep interacting there's
also link AIDS right where you can write
a comments in English and ask it to
convert the comments into link uh the
link codes for
you there is also Ling dojo this is from
this year right a project done in
calltech this is very impressive but I
think the most impressive thing that
everything is open source previous
projects they have many components that
you do do not have access to here
everything the data sets the models the
codes everything's open source you can
rebuild Lind on your own machine you can
run it locally you don't need to talk to
a server you can if you have a machine
with gpus if you have a new Mac you can
run Ling Dojo on your notebook the model
running in your GPU on your
notebook if you want to play with the
model you want to find tune the model
you can right this is really cool
because everything is open source right
I think this is one of the first
projects in this AI format where
everything is open
source these are there many other groups
working AI format for these are the ones
that are public they already publish
results they have websites but there are
many others just this week I talk to
three different groups that are building
AI for here in the Bay
Area there are many different
opportunities for Ling MAF liby and AI
right first one is we can get machine
checkable proofs no hallucination right
we have Auto formalization right the
idea that you can converse English in
formal math in formal one enabling this
technology to a completely new crowds
right
you can use AI to also refactor your
proofs change them apply
Transformations and you can have
verified code syn sizers
right we CI generating codes but we
don't know if the code does what we want
imagine a future where the code comes
you give an a spec the AI gives you back
the codes and appr proove that this this
code meets your specification or it
gives back your codes and allows you to
ask questions about the code does it has
this property and they I says yes here's
the
certificate this can change how we do
math and computer
science there's also lots of community
excitements for example uh Thomas here
he wrote a system where you can write
systems of referential equations prove
properties about the systems and
automatically gets an
ations did all because all that's
because L is extensible right he creates
uh this is a GSL he created for stating
properties about his
system and then this stuff Al also
generates the animation for
you another cool thing that's one of
matician was really happy when he
realized that is that because formal
math is data right you can refactor it
for example suppose we have a results
that uh uses holds for
Fields you can write a small script that
try to replace everything that is is
using a field with a ring and check if
the proof still goes through if there
still the proof still goes through you
have generalized the results right this
is cool right you can write thist
scripts and they actually generalize a
bunch of things by just running scripts
like that and the coolest part is that
we cannot just generalize the results
but you can propagate it the
generalization here he was pointing out
imagine you generalize a results from a
paper written 50 years ago and now you
want to propagate the result to every
single paper that depends on your paper
how do you do that it's really hard to
do that with formal mathematics you can
do that with a push of a button
right the conclusion of the talk is like
Lan is extensible to improver you can
find more about L our website you have
many links to articles in popular
science magazines
videos uh it enables centralized
collaboration I believe the math Li
Community will change how mathematics is
done in thoughts uh the community is
amazing and one thing that's a message
it's not about proving it's not about
making sure your proof is correct for
mathematics is way more than that it
reduces your cognitive loads allows you
to understand complex objects and proofs
get new insights and as shy says when he
quoted when he saw the results uh of the
when people formalized his result he say
for mathematics allow us to navigate
this thick jungle that's beyond our
cognitive power thank you very much for
your
[Music]
[Applause]
attention thank you for that very
inspiring talk uh take
questions thank you uh first of all
thank you very much for coming to talk
to us I I feel quite bit emotional like
you know I'm meeting lenus stals in
person can I ask you so for those of us
who don't exactly know that much about
uh Schultz's liquid theorems and such uh
if you go back maybe I don't know let's
say 20 years what would you say were
other great successes of mechanical
proof checking by lean and maybe by
others oh yeah going back 20 years lean
didn't even exist yeah well but that
many for me that are many successes
right for example comcert in like
comcert is this verified SE compiler
right is an amazing achievement many
influenced so many people in many
different universities built on top of
concerts there also the Four Color
theorum right by jorer a former
colleague of M it's Microsoft the F
Thompson also by
George there's also the cap conjecture
from Tom haes and Tom haes I didn't have
the opportunity to say but he he has a
huge role in the link story in 2017 Tom
haes gave a
talk at a seminar called Big proof and
he said I'm going to do my next project
he finished the capit conjecture and
says my next projects formal abstracts
I'm going to do using link and the goal
of formal abstracts was his dream is
that every paper in math would have a
formal statements the proof could be
still be formal but the statement would
be formal which
will he explains why this would enable
so many different things in that and
that talk Kevin Buzzard was there right
and Kevin Buzzard decided to Lear
because of that talk that Tom haes gave
he says if Tom is doing I'm going to use
Link to and Kevin brought the perfect
spaces everybody right so I'm super
grateful for
him yeah so uh ly has such an incredible
uh user community and as you mentioned
that you didn't really intend that to
happen especially for mathematics so
looking back uh can you see why people
gather around Le was it because of the
design of language or something else I
can only conjecture that right one thing
I think is extensibility right they
could extend they have so many
extensions sometimes they say oh we hate
this stuff you did we create our own
version yesterday someone was telling me
why there induction Prime and induction
right that two t do almost the same
thing but induction Prime is the
community version and they use induction
Prime they tell me I your version
sucks we implemented our own version
right way they can make the system their
own they have a tactic I have cases they
have AR cases they Implement with so
many gadgets and features would be
impossible for me to do all these bells
and whistles they wanted but they could
do
themselves giving this power to them
made a big difference
there's a question here that come back
to you
on yeah so maybe that's a little
philosophical my question so lean can
check proofs with AI you can create a
proof and then have it checked by lean
is there a way to create theorems that
AI will prove and then lean will check
and in the end the computers do do their
own math and we only sit on stand on the
sidelines and watch them do this it's
starting to show up a few months ago in
nature
we had a results right the AI was create
postulating new conjectures right things
will happen more and more but I strongly
believe at least in my lifetime we are
going to have ai as assistants they may
be exploring conjectures but they're not
doing by themselves they're working
together and I I I view AI as empowering
us right they Empower Us in so many
different
ways computers empowers Earth imagine in
the past G was an amazing he knew how to
calculate he was a fast human calculator
today no human is should be a fast human
calculator should be a great
mathematician Kevin buz tells me that
every math department has a problem
solver someone that got a gold medal in
Theo they are like this they know how to
solve these puzzles right but that you
don't have access to puzzle Sol you are
stuck may you may be brilliant but you
are not a good puzzle server you're not
a good human
calculator computers enable you AI will
enable one
day to you overcome these puzzles
automatically the same way with
computers we don't need to be a human
calculator anymore right then power
maybe one day they will replace I don't
I I don't think this will happen in my
lifetime hello thank you for an
interesting talk my name is yawa doas
I'm visiting PhD at Stanford University
and I'm really after your talk excited
about trying out lean my question is
related with its implementations and
capabilities for uh
nonlinear um arithmetics for real
numbers and some motivation behind my
question is that over the past few years
I can relate to the problems that you
mentioned in the beginning of your
presentation that some of the proof
steps on pen and paper are missing in
information Theory and
probabilities and um interactive proof
assistance are not too intuitive in this
case and SMG solvers when working with
nonlinearity for reals are also non
converging uh there was some promising
um der for implementation
that might have worked but it has some
numerical instability so I'm wondering
if I'm a researcher who like to try out
lean what would you suggest and
recommend uh in similar problems yeah
it's interesting yes I mean you if
yous they use cindal break the
composition uh it's powerful technique
but as you said sometimes times out
today is the is the best automation we
have for linear arithmetic proof systems
unfortunately s composition is still
open problem to get a proof a compact
proof certificate for this the same way
it times out is is G normous proof
certificates that this kind of solver
produces this is a
challenge uh but there are some some
lights in the end of the tunnel for
example last year a group at Brown
University by Rob
Lewis they connected link to a computer
hous system for computing GL basis the
cool thing about gr Bas is that the
certificates are
compact so you can call unrusted system
that computes the gret basis and now you
can check there's a efficient way to
check if it's correct or not the results
so you can they implement this bridge
and uh uh they presented in a summary
school at Brown if you search for it
it's really fun to see the students I
mean hether mcbath was giving the
lecture and she starts asking people to
solve this nonlinear Problems by
themselves and they start struggling and
suddenly she said okay let me show you a
proof Automation and she shows and
people start cheering in the room and
and one person comes to me and say wow I
never seen mathematician hearing not
doing a
presentation but this is
challenge yeah so maybe more like
general question so when you're reading
proofs some proofs are beautiful like
their proofs from the book some are like
really ugly both of them are correct so
does Lin come with the notion of like be
you know like
Beauty uh well the mathema the math Li
community they have their Notions of
beauty right some PO requests will be
rejected right saying this proof is a
mess right uh for meth Le the main
important thing is maintain ability
right can we maintain this proof right
it's the main notion of guy there and of
course they have coding conventions
naming conventions it's like the same
techniques we use for WR and codes
what's the naming are you following the
our naming convention are you following
our cing conventions for example I like
really long lines in MA they will not
take my codes I mean because I use
really long lines and they want 0 lines
you can't cross not eight columns sorry
you cannot have more than eight
characters in one line you have to break
because they want to make things rible I
tell people why don't you buy a bigger
monitor
hello um so let's say I have a tweet or
more interesting a agent a agent that's
us large language models can I use
foundational model that creates
embedding of uh a tweet or words in this
TW we treat H embedding as a symbol and
we try
to create a lean
code out of those symbols and see if the
Constructor proof and see if the proof
well converges or does not converge
right or whatever if it's true or not
um does it sound for you as a reasonable
way to address reasoning problems with
llms I'm not an expert in machine
learning right I'm more when I talk
machine learning people I always ask
them which apis from Le you want I can
expose the internals for example I help
them providing the internals of uh the
proof States the data structures they
want to access the internal information
to be able to train the machine learning
models but I have very little intuition
how this machine learn learning models
work sometimes it Blow Me Away I cannot
even understand when I play gpc4 how
come it can do
that I can't really give you any
guidance about machine learning I can
put you in touch with colleagues of mine
that are experts in machine learning for
for math uh but myself I can really
comment sounds plausible what you said
but I don't
know I'll give it to
him so I'm wondering a lot of L is about
proofs but I feel like maybe in
mathematical reasoning you also think a
lot about examples and maybe cter
examples is there some place in Lan
where you can incorporate something like
I try to prove a theorem and instead
link comes back and says oh this theorem
is actually wrong here is a counter
example or or maybe even something more
subtle than that well we want coun
examples we don't have good support for
counter examples now there are to like
quick check
iname but this is only for simple things
right only builds counter examples for
very simple things for Cutting Edge
mathematics things are so abstract that
constructing contract example
would be gigantic objects right you saw
that you have uh that statement I I
showed you have to build a commutative
ring you have to build a ring you have
to build sub module you have to build so
many things for the counter
example it's quite tricky
for maybe in the future we have tools to
do that you can like oh from these
instances of ring commutative ring try
to build a context example using these
instances here like I'm feeding you some
examples of this mathematical objects
and ask decision to build a counter
example using them I can see that
working but working from F there I would
be really
surpris yeah so in a sense Len is
realizing the the dream of David Hilbert
uh 100 years ago which is build this me
mechanical Foundation of of mathematics
uh but then also came along saying that
you can't do that like you can't have a
consistent formal system that's all
powerful so like what is the limitation
of Le uh and for sure for sure I mean we
hit problems that we have to extending
the the foundations right to be able to
attack this may happen right but in
practice this incompleteness is not a
big deal right you have very few results
incompleteness results in mathematics
real one right the example that g builds
is very artificial right we hit Real
Results right Independence of the
continuous hypothesis right but these
are exceptional results right in real
mathematics is not a real thing of
course one day we may have to increase
the power of the foundation
right but we hope the same we hope that
when this kind of thing happens in the
future right we will be able to move the
mathematical Library automatically to
the New Foundation
right it's keep in mind that even if we
don't have to increase the
foundation no system will exist forever
right pring languages die one day lean
will die and something else will replace
it right even if the foundation is the
same but it's a better system like we
have programming languages are both two
Inc complete but one is more convenient
to use I strong believe that nothing's
whatever will be replaced by something
that has a stronger Foundation or
something is better better usability
better
scalability hopefully the maal library
will be
ported automatically to the new
system so you and you're talking of this
nice uh tweet or something from uh Gren
and you also mentioned that you know
when you initially created lean or lean
4 I can't remember your your priority
was not a uh language for mathematics or
even a interactive theor improver but uh
you know a better general purpose
programming language in many ways and uh
we saw one example of a sort of export
um from the development of of lean with
this functional blend in place stuff
this is sort a sort of General technique
in programming languages and I think
it's getting implemented at some others
so how do you see going forward With The
Lean frro or even your personal
priorities managing the sort of lean as
a language as a programming language
general purpose programming language
versus lean as the you know tool for
math lib or the tool for mathematic
mathematics more
broadly yes
uh right now in defo we have two
missions we want to support the
mathematical Community right and we want
to achieve self-
sustainability what do we mean by
achieving self- sustainability we want
to having industrial applications but in
five years the only thing that we think
we can do is to have Ling as a system
that's for software
verification and Hardware verification
companies we hope in five years we're
going to have le being users in many
software companies Hardware companies to
verify hardware and software and they
will be donating money to the link
Foundation right that's our goal maybe
10 years we can have Ling as our
mainstream programming language
this is really complex effort get to get
a system at the level is a mainstream
programming language python took more
than one decad to get mainstream
programming language R same
thing hopefully one day we'll get there
but don't hold your
breath all right uh thank you for the
great talk um I wanted to ask so you
said some of the users of lean are
students um and you said like even like
younger students so I was wondering like
let's say at the undergraduate level
right like let's say you have an
undergraduate come in they're learning
computer science they're taking discreet
math should they should we like alide
like problem sets entirely should we
just say write your proofs and lean
because you'll become a better not only
programmer but also mathematician
somehow yes for example the electr knows
like when people ask me this question I
always Point them to had Mac bath course
she thoughts for second here his
students at foran her elction notes are
beautiful I mean I think every student
will learn we understand proofs better
by following her lecture notes she has
many
exercises he she reduces the power of
the pref automation to make sure the
students are learning they're not just
using pre automation she has a really
nice setup where she reduces the power
of the system to motivate students to
learn cre proofs by
hands can I intervene uh so this is not
such an abstract topic um I teach
discret math at the University of
Pennsylvania and my colleague Benjamin
Pierce A couple of years
ago uh proposed why do we teach discret
math as math why don't we teach it in
um and guess who was very much
against
it the algorithms people the very theor
not you know systems people the very
theoretical algorithms people who do not
see any kind of rhy between between a
formalization of a proof and what
they would write as a proof I know this
full of algor
people I will try to escape through that
door and what they would write as as a
proof in in say their paper right they
they feel that that the kind of
attention to detail and is is
counterproductive and so I'm still
teaching discret math for algorithms
rather than discret math for for
programming language Theory I see I see
no yes don't hold your breath whoever
asked that
question um so you mentioned that the
math lib uh oh yeah sorry the uh the
math lib uh file is millions of lines of
code and I imagine hundreds of thousands
of of theorems so how would a user who's
writing a theorem and and wants to use a
a previously proven theorem how would
they go about finding it in in there I
imagine discoverability is is kind of an
issue yes yes uh and people are working
on that right that people working using
AI like the M AI example I gave there
are people that's just def you're
putting fragments of the name and you
search you have fuzzy mat in L you can
put fragments of the name of the the and
hope you're going to find it there's now
a new tool called Lugo that is like a
search engine for link where you can ask
give me theorems that you use for
example s and cosine we have done a list
of terms that mention these two
functions right uh but people this an
active area right uh and this is a big
if you ask anybody use using formal
mathematics it's the same thing when
you're using a big software Library you
spend a lot of time trying to find
functions in the library same thing in
my you spend a lot of time trying to
find theorems in the library but people
work on tools math is data right you can
write tools for searching the
library the on the board of
M yes this is a good technique sure they
do that yes yes yes they claim that's
the best SE change and you go there and
type the question they say yes it's
here um hello everyone I'm a freshman
here at Berkeley math major I'm having
I'm I happen to take like math 55 which
is discre math right now so I'm like a
perfect example of like students uh who
could use lean so my question is that
like is there any feature for like
intuitive ideas like imp proofs because
like for example we're now like learning
number Theory which like the first
proofs come to our uh class is like
proof like there are infinite infinitely
many primes and then there are such like
Steps in in proof that like it feels
like it's totally made up by someone who
is like so smart it was like 100 times
smarter than me and like there's no like
motivation for that so is there any like
feedback loop in lean that would tell me
like what's the like idea behind this
step like step by step so so that I can
learn this process
better is great I
mean same thing happens in programming
right sometimes you're reading a program
how they came up with that sometimes
they put in a comment explaining why how
they came up right but the cool thing
about the infinite Prime is there are
YouTube videos with people showing how
to prove their infinite primes in lean
right there is one magical
step and they will tell you in the
YouTube video how they how they did it I
mean uh but in general yes I mean it
would be great if people
document this kind of intuition in their
proofs maybe AI will help us one day to
to explain the intuition behind St but
in principle people can WR magical th
remember the IMO example where it came
up three times parameters for that piece
of pref automation you may ask how did
it came up with this a minus B here B
minus C and C minus
a yeah it would be great if this
information is there in the file to
maybe in the form of a comment but in
principle the same thing can happen for
mathematics by definition does not solve
this problem it's up to the person
writing the proof to document just how
they came up
this okay so it's almost seven so maybe
one final question
yeah yeah you said that it can be um
sort of a Leng lengthy process because
to to formalize the proof because you
can't just say something is obvious uh
so do people like um you know uh
temporarily say that this step is like
an acum or like this implication is an
action and so you can sort of gradually
go from yes Lind there something called
sorry is like saying this is is sorry
this St trust me of course you can in F
they will never take your PR if it has
sories but in your machine you can keep
in your in your you can fork and save
your intermediate results full of sories
there uh but I I see people discusting
ah there only five stories
left and sometimes it's funny they
remove sorry but
put it's like it's a
fight but people get really excited when
they remove all stories and many of them
they come to me and say wow you built
the best video game
ever all right so thank you so much
Lardo for a great
[Applause]
talk and the extensive